a powerful winter storm is snarling
travel for millions of Americans heavy
snowfall is creating a dangerous commute
for drivers in the Midwest more than a
thousand flights are canceled the storm
will impact people who live in states
from Montana to Maine Dean Reynolds is
in Chicago where about a foot of snow is
expected dean good morning good morning
well we're here along Chicago's North
Avenue beach and I doubt if anybody's
going to go swimming today the snow has
been falling since about 6:00 p.m. last
night but it's been kind of a light snow
sort of a powdery snow and the
accumulations have not been as great as
predicted though businesses and schools
in the Midwest have closed for the most
part as the snow hits about ten states
in the region mayor Emanuel says some
people in the city should be prepared to
be snowed in by this storm now
forecasters called for a foot or more of
snow but they are now scaling that back
to maybe 50 percent of their original
prediction and I think I can speak for
all of us here when I say very few of us
are disappointed Nora well said Dean
thank you so much